are men trash Oh CIS heterosexual men
absolutely especially white men what
rights do you think that men have that
women don't today a woman where do you
get off just saying that this particular
group of people are trash like yes his
hetero whatever just really especially
the white ones just came out blasting
and are probably like underrepresented
it started off a great intent but you
have people who abuse the system the
hatred of masculine energy it's like
anti-men today I'm out here and I'm
asking is feminism still relevant in
today's society yeah absolutely if
anything it's more relevant now than it
ever was
dumb ass you
right
sparrassment of of riches and rights and
says that she that women have it harder
than ever before you dumb purple-haired
nitwit ah you could have hit her with
the obviously feminism's still relevant
today you know we built this country man
but women at the same time got to supply
more men right with no women the world
doesn't go around if you look at like I
feel like black guys are the realist in
public interviews have you noticed that
like I feel like they're always the ones
that just like say it how it is yeah
they're all pretty is based the right
word for that am I using it correctly
yeah am I racist for saying that or is
that just like a pattern recognition I
feel like for the most time they're like
yeah this shit's dumb based on what
we've seen yeah there are a lot of black
guys who are just saying it like it is
no [__] yeah if you look at like
domestic abuse for instance we know that
it happens 91 of domestic violence
crimes that cause injuries are against
women yes 83 of domestic abuse victims
who are subjected to more than you know
of all gender but it seems to be like
disproportionately like affecting women
feminism is still relevant in today's
society yeah I definitely think it is
they put up with a whole lot of [__]
that us men just don't have to do it of
course it's relevant throughout history
women have been discriminated against uh
it is but I think it's changed a lot
feminism started out as women's rights
and now it has skewed into something
entirely different than what it was are
we going too far did we do this and all
the rest of that instead of being angry
now it's morphed into something that's
more preaching like a superiority over
men kind of stance like I work with some
people who would consider themselves
heavy feminists and they are constantly
dogging on men and they openly say I
hate men I would say that as long as men
are alive feminism is always going to be
relevant why
because men it's like today we're more
polarized than ever before what the [__]
because men because men because because
my because my phone because my phone lit
up and it told me to isn't that so funny
that like like words that just like pop
up on your phone is like what makes
people believe [__] like this is what
the Matrix has come to like they're
they're so smart these people that
they've put this device in everyone's
hands where they can send alerts and
make you believe anything they don't
even fully rely on their own experience
I know it's crazy more than I can count
young women with excellence loving kind
fathers who were good providers protect
the family always gave them everything
they ever wanted and they're out in the
street screaming and railing against
toxic masculinity and men and how awful
men are like you've got a brother who's
an angel and a father who is a model
Citizen and one of the best fathers I
know and I'm talking about many people
and they're out there screaming I hate
men what's the matter with you what's up
with this guy Russell there's a radical
feminism
but in today's like a Nuance is it
considered sexist to even question yeah
and if I had to be honest with myself
could I do it without my own bias I
guess we gonna see what rights do men
have today that uh women don't oh let's
go down the list a woman can still walk
a street and not feel protected versus a
man can I think we all happy women can
walk down the street and not feel
protected first of all there's a couple
ways to dispute that if you go with a
man then you might feel more protected
you could arm yourselves but then these
people are also anti-guns and then the
last thing is they think that men are
just safe to walk the streets alone at
night yeah like I would just walk around
with my headphones and because I have a
piece of dude I'm just like good yeah
like if there's two guys I'm I'm not
just screwed she's just in it let alone
her just repeating [__] that she heard
from some angry feminist oh they're so
delusional if anything at night as a guy
you're more likely to get to get screwed
over because they're you're gonna get
robbed or something like I never walk
alone at night with just my headphones
in ESP like a city more or less I think
I think there's a lot of things that go
into it that are far beyond sex no I
think as a girl you're more likely to be
like approached like as if you're
walking at night or anything alone like
yeah you're more likely for people to
come up to you but like getting
assaulted I feel like it's a guy like I
feel like people like it almost happens
to me a good amount where like people
just want to beef with you for no reason
guys just get angry when they see other
guys they're if they're crazy right that
happens all the time like all the time
in the city people just want to fight
you and you just have to like know how
to just like get away from that
situation yeah that's happened to me
countless time and I've just never gone
like into the altercations because I'm
not an idiot but then there's also the
hot head townies that are like yeah guy
I'll [__] you up guys and then they want
to fight over nothing and it's like bro
like why it's just so stupid like if you
want to fight go to the ring duke it out
like a man you know and are able to walk
out maybe in whatever they want to wear
or you know be able to stand strong
through societal pressure men can walk
out with whatever they want to wear but
she doesn't acknowledge that a lot of
females value is in their beauty so if
you're gonna walk around flaunting that
that's like a guy walking around holding
a bunch of his money it's it's the same
thing you see what I'm saying there am I
crazy yeah and she also just said that
men can walk through like life or
Society what did she say just I want to
be exact you're absolutely right I know
I'm right about everything
and can I think we all have equality
when it comes to laws men are able to
walk out maybe in whatever they want to
wear or you know be able to stand strong
through societal pressure I feel like
able to stand strong through societal
pressure so now you're saying women
aren't strong enough to stand through
societal pressure okay maybe that's a
you problem not a man problem yeah maybe
that's your problem if you don't that's
that's mind-boggling that's no
self-accountability the fortitude to get
through life get through a day of oh I
had to go to work and I had to drink my
Starbucks and it was too hot and I had
to now I have to go home patriarchy and
sit in my dirty apartment maybe you
should [__] a filthy pig maybe you
should clean find a toxically masculine
male I just assume that I'm just like
not talking I just assume all these
girls have filthy Apartments they do
don't go out with any feminists they're
dirty artistically just going into like
a corporate setting if you look at how
women are rated on performance or you
versus men the language that's used you
know assertive versus bossy or dynamic
individual tell me a study you read
about that or did you just hear some
[__] on of you talking about that I
can't
I can't they did this is just such old
blah blah blah blah talking points I
know you don't get in trouble for being
you know nobody's calling anybody bossy
in the office I was in Corporate America
for years no one's like you're bossy
you're acting in the workplace I do
think that they're a societal Norms that
place women in a disadvantage absolutely
I think it's so friends for pregnancy
right there's no loss it's it's just
like my my like my um what would be the
class I don't know this it just feels
like I'm listening to like my high
school women lectures like this this is
exactly the same exact terms they're
just regurgitating with with no
explanation behind it no this is
Advantage absolutely I think it's so
friends for pregnancy right there's no
washing employers can't like fire you if
you're pregnant they're like abortion
for instance like that's a law that like
only affects women right about the only
thing that's just kind of explained by
like biological differences actually
affect women because you were killing a
man's child when when how is it that
that child that a man has zero say over
whether or not his child field gets
killed yeah but he has to pay for it
regardless yeah no but
nobody affects women no it doesn't it
off and maybe a man doesn't want a child
and if a woman can't get abortion then
he has to deal with it but tough [__]
you want to dance you got to pay the
band do you think today that women have
certain privileges that men don't have
yeah part of that goes into being able
to say certain things that you know men
would would get scolded for they can
just talk completely out of their ass
freely you're not allowed to say nothing
back do you think let's say like do men
have problems let's say that women don't
experience for example in statistics
like men have higher rates of suicide
and you know obviously men die more when
it comes to like Wars women can go to
war yeah but uh it's true who's
overwhelming they always say that stuff
like well they can like they can but
it's like if we're going to war and your
life depends on it would you rather it
be 50 50 men and women or all men me all
men no I'm saying like even this girl
like if if there was like there was no
camera here and it was just a piece of
paper and she had to say like would you
rather would you want to be like
included in the draft or would you
rather the mango and if you even just if
you want to win who would you rather go
are you that brainwashed to where you
think that having half women and Half
Men wouldn't be the same as an all-male
Force it's crazy it but they would say
she would say it should be 50 50. that's
crazy to do it but that's crazy if it
came down to it respect to the women in
the military too it's just like great
respect to them I I I I don't have the
didn't have the Constitution for that
but to get to to pretend if I'm running
an army I would want all men am I racist
for that well there are places in there
are places if I'm going to war places
that I believe women can do great things
for a military I don't think it's on the
front lines yeah you know there's a lot
of other work you know that's you know
strategy and typing and sewing and
things
tell you about it I'm not even gonna say
it no I'm just kidding going to war and
dying Wars yeah men I'm not gonna argue
that I mean I feel like the war thing is
a little hard to get into just because
for the majority men are going to war
it's not really a woman going to war so
of course more men die why do you think
that is I feel like that's just because
it's kind of like the roles that Society
betrayed forever ago men are warriors
and men are the ones that are fighting
and then women do you think more women
should go into war them absolutely not
that's no no woman should ever go into
any military but wouldn't that be going
against equality if you're barring women
from going in the military then well I'm
not saying barring but I'm saying like I
feel like as a woman you should know
that you're not going to be putting
yourself in a healthy situation going
into the military because like it's
harder to be a woman in the military
than it is to be a man I think that
feminism is also it's almost an excuse
for Behavior flashing your tits or
something like that you know behaviors
like that like but if a guy wanted to
pull just just his balls out you know it
would be it would be a little less
socially accepted for sure and I agree
with that yeah do you think in this
sense that men have less privilege man
in a dress then it's in a woman
preschool
preschool assembly
privileges
off I think I'm pretty privileged lot of
black people probably don't say their
privilege so that's kind of how I look
at it we need to just stop looking and
thinking everybody got greener grass and
kind of just accept the fact we're not
in a third world country you know with
Russia invading us or some [__] you
know what I mean like life ain't that
bad it's 78 sunny out chill the [__] out
and your highest [__] right now aren't
you I'm cooked thank you
now I don't know what to exactly make of
what I'm about to experience it may
explain what's happening with society
today
an experiment called Universe 25 created
a mice Paradise with an abundance of
food and water the aim was to study
behavior over a time period in an
attempt to explain human societies it
was all good but after 315 days
something unexpected happened the
population reached 600 and hierarchy was
formed with larger Road and starting to
attack and caused male rodents to
collapse psychologically under those
conditions social behavior broke down
this led to a new class of males called
Beautiful males who only care for food
and sleep and isolated aggressive
females who didn't want to reproduce and
eventually the society collapsed because
the lack of reproduction and lack of
care for their young and the scary part
is is that after repeating this
experiment 25 times the same results
were observed over and over again a
viral Facebook post through parallels to
today's society with weak feminized men
with no protection instincts and overly
aggressive females with no maternal
instincts we need to kill all men it's a
bit of a stretch but is it possible that
that's what's happening in the west
today is the negative is that really
that much of a stretch though or is he
just saying that for the YouTube video
because I don't think that that that's
much of a stretch women becoming more
masculine every day and men becoming
bigger [__] men just want to eat they
don't even understand why it's important
to be masculine as a man and feminine as
a woman like they don't even the left
doesn't even comprehend that anymore
they're like why do you need to be
strong as a man what does it even matter
so the men are depressed basically just
want to eat and sleep like the mice and
the women are angry and don't want to
reproduce oh how many girls do you meet
nowadays that are like I don't want to
have babies angry aggressive and not
nurturing dude and the girls lie to
themselves too I was just with a girl in
Tampa and I was talking to her and she's
like yeah I don't want to have kids and
I'm like that's such a lie like I was
like I'd bet my life you're gonna have
kids by the time you're dead I mean by
the time um you're like 50. like I was
like when you're 50 I already said this
tour like I don't give a [__] with girls
I'll say it to them I was like when
you're 40. you're telling me that you're
gonna be happier alone with like money
rather than having kids with you and
like a nice big family and she was like
oh well I guess you're right like in two
seconds I changed her mind about her
thing where she was like I don't want to
have kids I already told her I was like
yes you're definitely gonna have kids
one day like that is such an insane
thought can you stop banging on the
table it's driving me crazy reaction of
feminism coming from the fact that not
only are women struggling but also men
let's take a closer look and see what
this really means may I ask you like
what are some like examples of misogyny
that you face oh let's see I went
through there's one time I'm a
Psychology major we were tasked with
counting how many times we got cat
called I realized every time during that
month I went to a gas station at night
time I got Capcom I've seen some of my
guy friends literally make 30 grand more
than some of my girlfriends and just
because they're men but let's say that
the pay Gap does exist why wouldn't
firms just hire women then they have to
find probably Quote us at this point do
you think there's quotas for men
no probably not there's a lot more men
in power in the top one percent a lot of
the women are the ones left in the dust
there's definitely like in the top one
percent I think there's definitely
stupid thing out of here for sure but
let's say like taken seriously I don't
want you running my life you're an idiot
Autumn right like most suicides are men
you know most people with depression are
men do we sometimes ignore that to maybe
showcase disparities where it might not
exist yes men do have a disadvantage at
that point so is it fair to say then
that both genders at this point maybe
have disadvantages in certain situations
but when it comes to the law they're
pretty equal and even opportunities yes
it does have that societal influence
more from a social standpoint it's not
necessarily what is placed in the law
but it has everything to do with how
people interpret the law for themselves
with women it's you have to jump through
all these barriers in order to even be
elected in an office however I did hear
though like for every male college grad
there's two women College groups you're
telling me Kamala Harris is Vice
President because is it not because well
I can't say that she was active he he he
flat out said that he was choosing her
because she was black and she was a
woman
I can say that yeah I know the president
said that he was going to choose a woman
and then he chose her because she was a
black woman that was literally about to
say that and I was like wait I can't say
that yeah but I guess I'm right I mean
the president said it he admitted to it
he said it in choosing his yeah his
running mate so that just dismantles her
argument because literally the vice
president is Vice President because
she's a black woman and I also don't
believe her she gets cat called every
day I don't believe it unless she is
just hanging out in the skeviest of
skeevy places I remember all six times
I've gotten cat calls it's amazing or to
even be elected and off this however I
did hear though like for every male
college grad there's two women College
grads and I think I believe most college
uh students are actually women so I
guess what would you say to that I know
that women are probably like
underrepresented in like the military or
in trade school so men might find more
interest in doing that instead of like
getting a bachelor's so like that's like
a whole career path that like women
really aren't being concerned how this
girl talks to Target like it's hard to
even listen to words because like men
like they want to go to like the
military and like men and like women
want to get like Bachelors crazy you
ever bring a girl home like that she'll
have one conversation with me before I
fix the way she talks or if she's never
coming back it was much I mean I guess
what do you say that there's probably
different interests in general between
the genders now there's like much more
of a push to get women to stem so
there's like more of that but when I was
younger there wasn't really that going
on
there was when you were younger this has
been going on for over 20 years pushing
women into stem and pushing girls into
stem classes so just what are they
talking about with your complaint they
just can't they'll pick up on a talking
point and they'll just run with it
without ever doing any homework because
they just want to feel like victims
because you know what it is when you
feel like a victim then that is the
reason you're unsuccessful because
you're a victim and it's society and not
like you could have just played your
chess pieces better you could have just
played you could have upgraded your
character better yeah you're exactly
right I'm I'm right about everything
hood is the only thing holding you back
that's it but your chess piece is better
and the way she talks I mean for the
love of God if somebody came in for an
interview and was like yeah and so then
I was like yeah once uh when I when I
went to college and you know it was
there I had an internship and it was
like at a marketing uh agency I believe
we're done we're done I wouldn't even
sit through the interview go home I used
to just mess with the girls once I told
like second semester and I told them all
I was dropping out and I would just mess
with them I would just be like yeah I'm
just like I'm just like dumb like it's
just like I just I just don't feel like
doing school you know I just like to
just like do nothing like and they'd be
like what's wrong with you
why would you even say that
it's dumb broads it's just fun messing
with them like I just can't help but lie
to girls I'm sorry like if I'm talking
to them I just can't take them seriously
a lot of the time
like if I'm out if I meet them out or if
like especially if I have no attraction
I used to have like fake names when I
went out and like guys would talk to me
at a club but like it was you know it
was right after entire Tales it was
right after like we generated like a ton
of money and she's like I was like yeah
I'm dropping out and she was like what
why what are you gonna do what do you
mean you're dropping off
kind of hard just mess with them like it
doesn't matter like who gives a [__]
yeah I used to do that too that's where
you get it from I can't help myself what
are you gonna do the question does
feminism account for the advancements
made or will they have happened
regardless and if so is feminism more
important than ever to preserve progress
and also to prevent regression towards
inequality yeah
we are so spoiled that people need a
purpose in their lives yeah and these
people have no purpose so they make
would they make up a problem they create
an issue they say that feminism isn't
super important and it's and and if
you'd if you don't participate now in
this that all of our progress is going
to be lost and we have no rights same
with the black lives matter [__] yeah
yeah so they they have to find a cause
to to latch onto instead of taking that
energy and going and building your life
if women are so great and so capable
show me go ahead I'll be holding me back
the patriarchy [__] the men this gender
white males are all holding us all back
y'all voted for Biden y'all voted for
Joe Biden who was a rate you could look
at look at clips of him saying the most
racist horrible [__] his daughter's
diary had him it explained how he would
get in the shower with her when she was
a little girl he he video after picture
and video after video of him sniffing
and touching little girls and you can
see them going like uh you know the one
son turned out okay Hunter is a legit
actual crackhead who slept with his dead
son's wife and then cheated on her with
a stripper and has a daughter with that
stripper who he he'll he has he pays
child support too because he has to but
he's suing the the woman because she
doesn't even want the child to have his
last name they are a bunch of low lives
you want to talk about rotten men and
they all voted for him but they hate men
yeah okay pull yourself together that's
like insane you didn't know all that
[__] that I just told you you know your
face looked a little surprised yeah no
but it's actually crazy to think that
like the president's son is like a crack
addict like that or at least was like
that's crazy like that is so insane like
you think the president's family would
be like so prestigious like they all got
their phds they didn't drink nothing
yeah crack addict like if there's a kid
that does crack in the neighborhood
everyone knows about it let alone the
president's kid doing it that's insane
let's just keep going should it should
remain originally it's not a toxic thing
again what modern society has morphed
into especially you know things like
social media it has turned it into more
of a a superiority kind of cloak than it
is actually pushing equal rights so it
did make me think
actually Mill inequality in the west and
in a video titled exactly that seems to
be the case my latest book is of boys
and men why the modern male is
struggling and what to do about but is
he just one of those red pill
misogynistic cisgendered anti-feminist
and what he found through his research
is that women are leaving Men Behind in
advanced metrics like education and the
workforce in the 70s Title IX was
implemented to close the 13 gap in
college degrees between men and women
but now there's a 15 Gap in favor of
women with degrees and so today there's
evidence that there's inequality on both
sides
and as feminism has pushed more
representation for women in stem not
seeing similar efforts for men and
female dominated professions like heal
or health education Administration and
literacy and with blue-collar jobs
disappearing men need jobs and the thing
is there's availability for every one
stem job there's three heel jobs but
currently only 26 of those positions are
filled by men whereas 27 percent of stem
positions are filled by women so the
more controversial a topic the more we
need to look at the Nuance but today are
we even able to or even want a
discussion in the first place our men
trash CIS heterosexual men absolutely
especially white men weren't you just
talking about equality oh
we have to have that Viewpoint because
of how much we've been attacked just by
that gender but you just said that all
straight men are trash like that's a
pretty big generalization don't you
think it definitely is it's not
necessarily something I'm gonna like
saying via statistics I'm saying via
experience are men trash
maybe if you like have that mindset that
a whole group is trash then maybe
subconsciously every time you talk to
them you're talking to them like they're
[__] and then that energy gets
reciprocated back to you because if if
someone's talking to me like I'm [__] I
can you can tell and then it's like all
right [__] you purple haired [__] I
don't want to listen to you so get the
[__] out of my face I must be a CIS
gender hetero white male because I also
don't want to talk to that [__] no I'm
saying I don't know what I'm saying
no I like my dad he's not trash so most
men are trash I don't think men are
trash men just have more advantages but
like I said like I wouldn't want to be
on the front lines of like you know some
arms yeah
it should be hamburger meat for your
country it's a huge advantage to be
enlisted in our own any of our Armed
Forces right now while our stupid
president ramps up world war three and
you look at China and Russia as a unite
getting ready to unite against us can't
even walk up the [__] stairs yeah
yeah men have it so easy they 100 does
so I wanted to ask the same but the
reverse are women trash them uh no I
don't think anyone's strapped I like
people I think that there are some
people that have had really bad hand but
in general I would like to think that
most people are good what would happen
if we said that women are trash I say it
oh yeah yeah I think they're trash too I
thought you're a feminist I'm not a
feminist no maybe a little misogynistic
now I'm just kidding all kidding aside
in order to have a discussion there
needs to be mutual respect and if equals
joking do they mean that that's the most
important thing he said that there needs
to be mutual respect hey a lot of these
people are at least that lady was saying
she likes people I don't [__] like
people after she said a whole bunch of
[__] about men yeah she just seems dumb
she doesn't seem harmful the other one
is just the little purple haired thing
with the lip thing is hateful yeah she's
just hateful it's the call it's the
college degree that like if I didn't
critically think and I just accepted
everything that school told me I would
think like those people because that's
what the school system tells you to
believe I I don't I'm gonna just go
ahead and say that I feel like your
father and I had some part in you having
a different perspective active because I
always even when you were little I
talked to you about current events you
know we talked about it made me read the
news for a while yeah I mean we you knew
what was going on in the world not you
know you have your finger on the pulse
all the time but whenever there was a
big news story we we talked about it so
yeah and and we talked about right and
wrong around that so you had some
balance thank God what do other people
they send their kids to school they come
home maybe they a lot of families don't
even eat dinner together anymore we
always sat at that table and ate
together that was a big thing and if
you're not doing that with your family
you better stop the presses and start
doing that [__] and you're getting me
busy we're busy we'll get unbusy and get
your priorities straight because kids
sitting at the kitchen table talking to
their family will end up sharing
families nobody's busy nobody's busy I
don't buy it because if you look at any
of their screen times there's like five
hours on Instagram and Tick Tock and
Snapchat every day no people you're not
busy like you're not busy you could
spend half of the time you spend on
social media research searching money
spending time with family doing anything
and it's so much time everybody thinks
their kid's going to be the next NHL
player yeah I know right but but I
didn't overdo it with you still you
still had balance we weren't in a hockey
rink seven days a week and you had you
know the other kids going to be a piano
virtuoso and then they have you know
every they're going to the you know the
Russian math class and they're doing
this and that because their kids going
to be the best the best human ever and
meanwhile the kid never has any down
time to sit and learn how to share meals
with their family and talk about the day
and what did you experience and what did
you learn and let's let's talk let the
parents lead the values of the family
yeah because there's no time together
and you did have that and I think it and
I think it shows you think women are
allowed to say that men are trash but
men can't say that women are trash
because I mean just based off of History
you know men have and men say that too
men say women are trash women are hoes
I've been the dominant sex I mean not
even really a hundred years ago women
were more of an obtained piece of
property sometimes lemons are trash well
I think more men than women for sure
it's one of the many double standards
that's because 100 years ago women were
a piece of property not here in America
I and there were parts of the world
where they they basically still are you
know there are there are nine-year-old
girls being given up by their families
for a couple sheep for a couple of sheep
or a bag of grain you know because
they're so poor and they are being
treated but or you know betrothed to 50
year old men it's disgusting but here in
America women work property no no get
your facts straight that's not even true
it turned into it it's no longer about
the quality of men and women it is more
the differences between men and women
and in recent times that history of
inequality has been exposed to no other
place than Hollywood with Hollywood sex
abuse Scandal growing by the day we need
two movements me too me too me too the
me too movement in 2017 raised awareness
to numerous stories of sexual abuse of
women in the workplace and Not only was
the movement successful in exposing
individuals like Harvey Weinstein it
even had an impact on public policy
through the passage of the laws to
prevent harassment in the workplace but
like anything the pendulum swings both
ways
despite his success the metoo movement
promoted extreme slogans such as believe
all women and along with it created a
climate of fear where innocent men were
unfairly accused I was just reputation I
was just thinking about that earlier how
like I'll honestly I don't even like
make the first move with girls like ever
because I just like I'm just like [__]
that like I'll go up and talk to them
and that's it like I won't even like
like I won't I don't even want to shake
your hand like I don't want to touch you
at all like I'll let like because if a
girl's interested in you she'll start
like touching your arm and [__] and it's
obvious or she'll like ask what you're
doing but like I don't even I don't
initiate that at all because it's like
terrifying it's absolutely terrifying
you don't even understand that's like
what it's like as a guy to have to worry
about this all the time and how much you
see the other girls where they'll act
interested in a guy and then they'll go
behind his back and say how creepy he is
but they're acting interested to his
face like that is a crazy thing to see
from from a from a guy's point of view
where a girl is doing that you're like
oh are they all just doing that with me
am I being creepy and I don't know so
I'm just like [__] it I'm just like not
gonna talk to them and then they wonder
why this good guys don't just come up to
them that's really disturbing as your
mother I worry about this stuff these
believe all women Hypocrites you have no
idea
I'm sure so many people in the comments
feel the same way destroy did Johnny
brutalize you and the most notable was
the Johnny Depp Amber Heard case where
herd wrote an op-ed alleging that she
was a victim of abuse and it wasn't
until four years after getting canceled
from everything when Depp won the
defamation trial for the false
allegations do you think that in a
certain way Pizza movement also went too
far it started off a great intent and
it's designed to have great intent but
you have people who abuse the system and
people who take advantage of it and they
see a Payday or time for fame and it
ruins it for the real people out here
who are actually victims me too it's for
True survivors it's cluster [__]
I've said this before like they don't
actually care about finding the truth
and stuff and getting Justice for the
victims because like if my daughter if
like if anything ever happened to her
maybe this is just a dumb a dumb point
of view but I'd say like let's go try to
get like some DNA or like get proof
while it's like fresh so that if you
ever do want to go to court about it we
can but they don't tell you to do that
it's like 20 years later now let's just
like call the guy out with no proof or
anything and then we're just supposed to
believe you yeah like that doesn't make
sense like if they actually wanted True
Justice you would say like make sure
you're getting as much proof as quick as
possible you're going You're trying but
it doesn't even improve necessarily that
it was a that it was an assault if you
have DNA oh yeah no I mean there's
plenty of times where it's they just
regret it yeah I don't try I don't trust
this young generation of women I don't
and it's a shame because they created
that mistrust no no if she's like if she
acts like distant like whatsoever I'm
just like bet stay there like I'm just
like
I'm not I'm not gonna like go and like I
don't know yeah try try with her stay
away from me yeah and it's the
unfortunate reality that any over
correction swings back's just as
strongly in the opposite direction so is
this what's happening in modern feminism
in the west today if so how can we
correct this over correction before it's
too late the best way that I can learn
from you is my city you heard me say
recently that because of what I see it's
with with a few exceptions but what I
see with female politicians who are in
the public eye and the way they scream
and in Congress and they're crying and
they're screaming and they're banging on
and things and they're shrieking and
they're shrieking and uh you know
someone like AO seizing now she needed
therapy after January 6th and she wasn't
even in the freaking building she was
two blocks away you know what you're
they're we that's weak leadership to me
that's the leaders of your country so a
woman is going to have to work harder
for my vote because the women that they
elected are so weak and shrill and
fragile that's not who I want I want I
want emotionally controlled intelligent
people who can make decisions
therapy after January 6 that's cool and
if you need she needed therapy she
should have kept it to herself you don't
show weakness to your whole population
yes so so women are going to have to
work harder for my trust and they
created that problem you let them know
I'm not the only one who feels like that
I talk to a lot of women who feel the
same way they're like yeah hell with it
I'm really trying to understand every
time I think you're done I'm done you
should keep going it's crazy so then I
could learn from you is by sitting down
and listening to you and really trying
to understand seeking to understand
where you come from and learning from
that Dynamic and that that dialogue I
say conversations like this right
absolutely I think that we need to get
rid of terms like feminism feminism is
more of like a suppression of masculine
energy essentially getting rid of that
sense of like dominance of one over the
other would be the the better Society to
exist in because if negative attention
wasn't enough it's now because coming
harder to be a feminist even if you're a
feminist for years the author of Harry
Potter J.K Rowling identified as a
feminist who advocated for women's
rights whether it be speaking out or the
donations or advocacy but in 2020 it was
as if none of that mattered anymore
after expressing concern on Twitter what
constituates a woman she was berated by
activists as misogynistic and most
notably a turf
turf stands for trans-exclusionary
radical feminists and is an acronym used
by trans activists to describe someone
as transphobic for believing that gender
is based on biological sex due to this
rallying has faced strong criticism to a
point where it has impacted her Legacy
the new video game Hogwarts Legacy is
labeled so controversial to a point
where twitch streamers are refusing to
play it for fear of being called
transphobic similarly it's a secret so
stupid
who cares what this fat blue haired
bimbo thinks who gives a [__] like these
were the people that got made fun of in
school and no offense but like that's
the truth so like why are we the ones
giving them all of this praise and
attention now like who gives a [__] like
if I'm streaming video games and these
people don't want to watch me or they
want to cancel me I don't care who it is
who cares I don't care if it's a
blue-haired freak or or if it's anybody
any anybody on the other side either if
I want to watch play this video game and
I like it you're not going to scream me
out of doing it well that kind of that's
right let's listen to this because like
you also say this stuff like don't wear
this brand because you don't agree with
their ideologies so like if people
genuinely believe that the Harry Potter
[__] is like against their ideologies
and like evil like how you think some
companies are then it's the same logic
as yours I'm not screaming in the street
about it I just I just say get their
shoes off ew get those Nikes that make
you look so fly off no I thought you
know what I'm saying though that's all
you got to do is just back off you don't
like Harry Potter anymore because you
disagree with the author it's a video
game so throw your stupid books out what
do I go donate them to a library how
about how about the [__] this guy
made news he he was taking Harry Potter
books buying them and then cutting out
uh her name taking out the page with the
author's name and you know like he
bought them yeah and then taking you
know then etching the the name off the
front and then reselling them so that
you could still buy her book oh without
her name oh this was news this was like
when he had to pay for those books in
order to resell them okay but then he
sold them for profit yeah so he's making
so he's a g but he gave her money but he
bought the book yeah but he probably
doesn't even give a [__] about that
movement he's just like smart and he saw
where he could hop between money and
capitalize on these stupid blue-haired
bimbos I should have done that and made
a video on it that would have been
hilarious I I hope you're right and
that's what he was doing anyway that
would have been so funny if I got a
bunch of Harry Potter books and I made
like a Bia has a video flipping flipping
Harry Potter no name where we just put
it we just took a Sharpie and we got to
think of this [__] we gotta we gotta see
this quicker and make videos out of it
yeah I'm not wasting my time doing
broken [__] like that but you could have
sold you probably could have bought the
books for like what eight times I don't
think this guy got rich and sunny I
don't think this guy got all right let's
keep going some Masters inclusion that's
dividing the feminist movement from
within and confusing the original
message of equality for all what do you
say you're a feminist yourself
absolutely I wouldn't say I'm not a
feminist I just think that like the word
feminism needs to be redefined what
should it be called uh I don't know
seeking truth and Justice
so if women are hesitating to identify
with the movement it's likely due to the
impact of the extreme because if
equality is achieved through bringing
others down it's creating issues where
none exists perpetuating double
standards but with that said
feminism is needed while true equality
may be difficult to achieve and some may
not actually desire it but nothing
significant ever came about through
indifference the pendulum is ever
swinging and we need individuals who
push for progress and serve as a check
to maintain balance but today how can we
even navigate differences if we can't
even question the Nuance I guess it's up
to me to lead the way and it all starts
with exploring the unfamiliar thanks for
watching And subscribe if you want to
see more content where I turn Street
interviews into investigative journalism
and if YouTube gets it right you'll like
this shout out again Jen whatever how do
you pronounce your name I love your
videos I've been talking I knew a guy
named Jen that spelled his name that way
yeah he does a good job on these videos
he puts a lot of work into them yeah I
was I was texting with him he's a cool
guy actually very nice very nice my
friend thank you so much for watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram join my Discord and I'll see
you later
and my mom's Twitter
[Music]